anstelle dass ich ihn jetzt wie gewohnt
mein aufreger des tages präsentieren
möchten wir heute mit der nachricht des
tages starten der ukrainische präsident
seelands gerhard ein treffen mit
bundespräsident frank walter steinmeier
abgelehnt dieser wollte nach kiew reisen
bescheiden jetzt live nach kiew zu
meinem kollegen bild bietzker ronzheimer
der uns sagen wird was da vor sich geht
wohl doch eine these mitgebracht hat
halo
paulina für uns die nachricht des tages
und auch gleichzeitig die nachricht die
wir für bild hier exklusiv recherchiert
haben heute ukraine verbot für
frank-walter steinmeier für den
bundespräsidenten und das leid echter
krimi der heute passiert ist hierfür
haben mit verschiedenen formaten
gesprochen mit regierungsvertretern die
uns alle gesagt haben nein morgen wollen
wir ihn nicht da haben warum morgen
offenbar nein das ist fakt mittlerweile
wollte steinmeier zusammen mit polens
präsident duda und den drei baltischen
staat überhaupt dann von polen richtung
kiel fahren und dann hat der ukrainische
präsident sich erinnert er hat sich
daran erinnert wie frank walter
steinmeier zu russland stand dass er der
mit architekt der russlandfreundlichen
politik war dass er immer gegen karte
sanktionen war und dass er nicht zuletzt
nord stream zwei so vorangetrieben hat
wenigen minuten 100 ungefähr 30 minuten
waren es ungefähr nach unserer
exklusiven nachricht die wir bei bild de
vermeldet haben musste sich dann
steinmeier äußern ist ein bisschen
danach aus als wollte er dass diese
nachricht natürlich nicht öffentlich
wird aber als bild dann veröffentlicht
hat musste er sich äußern und hab dann
zugegeben dass er offenbar nicht
willkommen ist ich muss ganz ehrlich
sagen bei mir gibts da irgendwie zwei
herzen in der brust auf der einen seite
verstehe ich lade mir seelands geht er
schläft jeden tag nur drei stunden der
will waffen hier haben der wild nicht
dass noch mehr menschen sterben und
erinnert sich natürlich daran was frank
walter steinmeier für eine politik
gefahren habe die aus seiner sicht erst
dazu geführt hat also ich kann
menschlich diese ausladung total
verstehen auf der anderen seite frage
ich mich was das politisch strategisch
bedeutet und ob es am ende bedeutet dass
man ja in deutschland leute
gegen die ukraine auf bringt die man
eigentlich nicht aufbringen sollte was
feststeht nena und das ist auch meine
these ich glaube dass diese nachricht
die nächsten stunden und die nächsten
tage deutschland aufhören wird und uns
vor die frage stellt was haben wir bloß
alles falsch gemacht
ja ich glaube auch dass diese these die
nächsten stunden beherrschen wird ich
bin mit ihr einig das ist eine sehr
schwierige und auch vor allem
zweischneidige these ist ich bin
unverdächtig irgendwie putin das zeug
reden zu wollen ich habe die große
dokumentation über steinmeiers
verfehlungen in diesen tagen gerade
aufgeschrieben aber ich bin sehr im
zweifel ob das eine gute geste gewesen
ist die wirkungen die ausgehen sollte
von diesem besuch war europa steht
vereint mit der ukraine gegen moskau
gegen putin in diesem krieg jetzt zu
sagen okay wir stehen zwar vereint aber
den wollen wir nicht halte ich für
durchaus schwierig als signal mal
abgesehen davon
dass
steinmeier der einzige gewesen ist der
gesagt hat ich hab was falsch gemacht
ich hab richtig was falsch gemacht er
hat im prinzip seine komplette politik
in frage gestellt und gleichzeitig
möchte dann die ukraine aber mit seinem
langjährigen parteifreund olaf scholz
der nie so etwas gesagt hat weiter
waffengeschäfte machen das finde ich
nicht logisch und die kanzlerin zum
beispiel hat auch nie darüber auskunft
gegeben wie herr selensky früher bei den
besuchen sich zur deutschen politik
verhalten hat oftmals sind da
diplomatische lobhudeleien durchaus
üblich der dort der ukrainische
botschafter in deutschland wiederum hat
aus privaten gesprächen erzählt das ist
ein ganz komischer stil der sich da
langsam breit macht und ich finde das
signal vereint in diesem krieg gegen
putin hätte europa gut zu gesicht
gestanden fangen wir den ball mal auf
toll ich glaube oder ich hoffe du bist
noch in der leitung wie ist der
unterschied zwischen schweiz und ist
paul nach dort sonst nehmen wir die
natürliche sei noch da genau sowas fall
die frage würde ich gerne direkt an dich
spielen genau das was ralf gerade auf
also erklärt hat mit olaf scholz und
steinmeier wie empfindest du das
also erst einmal muss man sagen
dass diese ausladung nicht offiziell
passiert ist das ist ganz wichtig zu
sagen möglicherweise wollte sind
gigantisch dass das rauskommt und ganz
sicher wollte steinmeier nicht dass das
rauskommt wir haben dort mit
verschiedenen quellen gesprochen ist war
jetzt nicht so dass selensky oder jemand
in seinem umfeld
angerufen hat und gesagt hat 'jetzt
macht da mal was draus sondern das ist
durch lange recherche entstand das ist
vielleicht wichtig für den hintergrund
zu dieser geschichte zu sagen ich glaube
dass man da emotional reagiert hat dass
man gedacht hat moment mal steinmeier
wird jetzt wie hierher kommen warum
warum brauchen wir steinmeier denn aus
sicht der ukraine ist steinmeier niemand
der in sachen bringen kann das ist
niemand der ihn sagen kann okay wir
machen jetzt die sanktionen sofort das
wäre scholz also in sachen scholz hat
man keine alternative weil man weiß dass
ist der bundeskanzler gleichzeitig ist
es auch so lenski hat größere probleme
mit frank walter steinmeier und auch
größere probleme mit angela merkel weil
er sie halt dafür verantwortlich macht
dass die ukraine überhaupt erst in diese
situation gekommen ist dass olaf scholz
und seine partei da lange eine rolle
gespielt habe das blendet man so ein
bisschen außen kehrt viel mehr sagt man
okay der ist erst seit ein paar monaten
stück kanzler und da hat man keine
alternative mit dem muss man will man
zusammenarbeiten und andrej melik der
botschafter hatte dass er vor ein paar
tagen bereits angekündigt hinsichtlich
eines besuchs dass man lieber olaf
scholz und auch ein paar minister
hätten überhaupt andrej melik der gehört
natürlich zu dieser debatte dazu der
sehr hat er sich bereits angelegt in den
letzten wochen mit frank walter
steinmeier auf heftigste art muss man
sagen in den sozialen medien also hat
steinmeier kritisiert und hat dann ein
konzert eine einladung ausgeschlagen wo
er sozusagen in einem konzert mit
russischen musikern als gast bei wunden
sollte und hat dann erneut frank walter
steinmeier heftig angegangen also dieser
konflikt hat durchaus eine geschichte
herr heilmann können sie das verstehen
das behalten was ja herr stein
entgegengebracht wird also wenn ich sie
lenski die nicht übrigens sehr bewundere
für das was er in diesem lokal ihnen
krieg für die ukrainische bevölkerung
macht beraten hätte hätte ich ihn anders
beraten der die sache ja wie vor
alzheimer sagt so rausgekommen ist wer
eigentlich mein ratschlag die sollten
sich erst einmal in kiew noch mal
überlegen sie haben ja gar nicht
offiziell ausgeladen deswegen könnten
sie ihn jetzt auch noch offiziell
einladen ich glaube das wäre geschickter
aber die war es natürlich auch
steinmeiers besuch kann nur ein symbol
sein der besuch von olaf scholz würde
was bringen deswegen wäre aus meiner
sicht die richtige antwort der ampel
regierung
olaf scholz macht das was boris johnson
und so auch schon alle gemacht haben
also durch kämpfe laufen als sich dabei
dann auch fotografieren lassen ein
zeichen für die welt der war natürlich
mit einem versprechen der hand dran
kommen das geschehen sonst wenig sinn
das geschenk paar waffen ja ich meine
frau baerbock ich bin kein grüner vw
bank hat doch eindeutig recht und auch
die die die die aussage von frau
lambrich mit westlichen waffen können
die ukraine nicht sofort umgehen die mag
ja stimmen aber wer sagt eigentlich dass
der krieg im herbst nicht zu ende ist
und er ist er dann im ende wenn die
russen wissen sie kriegen
westliche waffen und werden daran
ausgebildet und hätten dann im herbst
noch eine bessere antwort die wir
hoffentlich gleich und die ukraine
hoffentlich gar nicht brauchen aber
ausschließen kann dass von heute abend
keiner aber das geht ja jetzt ein
bisschen durcheinander nicht als meinen
waffenlieferungen da wären wir
sicherlich gleich noch
ausführlicher darüber reden das andere
ist wir reden hier über unser
staatsoberhaupt und da ist genau das
richtige gerade schon gesagt worden ich
glaube dass das der weg wäre dass man
vielleicht hier noch mal zusammenkommt
es wäre eine chance gewesen ja also wir
reden darüber dass wir jene einheit in
europa in der westlichen welt mit der
nato als erfolg in den letzten wochen
hier glaube ich gegenüber russland eine
front gegenüber russland aufgebaut haben
und da wäre das eine chance gewesen
gerade die differenzen die da sind das
wurde ja eben auch gesagt dass mein
letzten jahre vielleicht hier fehler
sicherlich fehler gemacht hat dass sie
eine chance auch für eine aussprache
gewesen wäre ich glaube das wäre das
zeichen gewesen was von so einem besuch
hätte ausgehen können und die chance
vergeben herr petzold ari um sie noch so
der these wir äußern uns lassen die
stehen sie dazu also ich sehe es
politisch strategisch auch so der besuch
hätte mehr gebracht und der frau bringt
jetzt so gesehen diplomatisch wenig aber
ich kann es emotional sehr gut
nachvollziehen also die spd und frank
walter steinmeier damals als
außenminister sind halt eben keine
freunde der ukraine gewesen
bundeskanzlerin angela merkel auch nicht
auch das gehört zur wahrheit dazu man
hat es zu lange mit dem russischen
peaceman irgendwie probiert man isst
lieber zu putin geflogen lieber nach
moskau als nach kiew das hat man sich in
der ukraine eben gemerkt und es gibt
einen grund warum boris johnson als
freund der ukraine durch kiew marschiert
und von uns tut es eben keiner so und da
kann man über boris johnson lachen aber
seine werte und seine moral kompass der
stimmte der stimmte bei uns im
kanzleramt und auch im außenministerium
sehr lange nicht funktional kann man das
wirklich sehr gut verstehen wenn man
sich das wirklich vor augen führt es war
eine fast schon kumpelhafte nähe
zwischen steinmeier und zb seinem
außenminister kollegen sergej lawrow auf
ihrem lieben sergej dann gibt es sowieso
szenen wo sie sich am arm dieser trend
anhalten das ist schon schwer erträglich
man muss aber eben auch sagen eine
einladung von steinmeier hätte
die botschaft gehabt hier steht er vor
den folgen vor den scherben seiner
außenpolitik das wäre möglicherweise
auch stark gewesen und hätte die ganze
botschaft eigentlich auch unterstützt
ich würde gerne zu ende von teese noch
eine kurze frage an volle stellen und
zwar die frage wie wird es weitergehen
traum also wie glaubst du entwickeln
sich die dinge wird steinmeier
vielleicht doch noch hinreisen wie wird
sich die lenz kies haltung verändern wie
sieht es aus für die nächsten wochen mit
blick auf die ukraine und deutschland
und besonders steinmeier
also erstmal würde ich ralf
widersprechen dass bei einem
probenbesuch sozusagen mit polen und den
drei balten sich der fokus auf stein 100
außenpolitik gelegt hätte sondern er
hätte sich da so ein bisschen mit rein
geschummelt ja die guten in die gute
gruppe richtung hier vielleicht wir
hätten besser wird und er alleine
genommen
dass wir hätten das sicherlich
entsprechend kommentiert das stimmt aber
vielleicht ist es gerade aus dem grund
besser wenn man das etwas ausgeruhter in
ein paar wochen war auch immer macht ist
gehört ja auch zur wahrheit dazu da
steinmeier lenski sich schon mehrfach
getroffen haben zuletzt hier im
september oder oktober glaube ich
letzten jahre sind hier weil sie die
kennen sich ja als ja nicht so dass er
in den vergangenen monaten immer gesagt
hat man scheinbar will ich nicht die
hand schütteln sondern dass es ihm jetzt
passiert ich gehe davon aus dass man
sich wieder zusammen findet man muss
auch wieder zusammenfinden denn
deutschland ist eben oder wenn ich jetzt
von der frage ob wir genug waffen
liefern eines der wichtigsten länder
oder das wichtigste land mit in europa
da geht es auch um finanzielle zuwendung
und ganz ganz viel hilfe die wir der
ukraine geben dass davon bei aller
kritik nicht vergessen von daher glaube
ich wird man da wieder zueinander finden
und das muss man und zwar deshalb weil
dieser krieg in der ukraine grausam
bleiben wird und noch grausamer werden
wird als das was wir schon erlebt haben
wir müssen davon ausgehen dass mario
pohl in den nächsten tagen fallen wird
dass wir von zehntausenden toten deutsch
sprechen von weiteren gräueltaten von
denen wir vielleicht nie erfahren werden
weil das dann russisches gebiet ist und
keine unabhängigen journalisten dort
zugang haben und wir müssen davon
ausgehen dass der dom bass also im osten
ein heftiger angriff passieren wird auch
wir hier aus kiew werden sicherlich ende
der woche richtung osten fahren um
gemeinsam mit unseren kollegen von dort
zu berichten herzlich dankbar nicht nur
heute für deine einschätzung sein du
bist jetzt seit zwei monaten ja auch
schon vor ort und berichtet jeden tag
und wir freuen uns wenn wir morgen
wieder die ihr zuhören können für ein
update